[Musique]
salvador de bahia un dimanche matin jour
de détente sur une plage à la mode
au milieu de la foule de danseurs
improvise d'une capoeira
c'est une danse et en même temps une
lutte très populaire à salvador le
berceau de la capoeira
au bout de la plage justement un cours
de capoeira commence diago mène la danse
la capoiera été créé par les esclaves
africains qui sont arrivés ici au brésil
au départ c'était une façon de combattre
pour se protéger des blancs
aujourd'hui on peut considérer ça comme
une profession il ya des gens qui vivent
de la terre très rare ici à salvadore
ailleurs la capoiera peut aussi
simplement servir à conserver la forme
ici elle est très forte à cause de nos
racines elle vient de notre passé
un rythme et des chants venus d'afrique
des techniques transmise depuis plus de
deux siècles la capoeira est une
tradition bien vivante car les esclaves
ont profondément marqué la vie et
l'histoire de salvador
[Musique]
retour aux origines lorsque les
portugais découvre cette belle jour de
la toussaint il la baptise la baie de
tous les saints et en 15 100 49
il fonde une ville nouvelle
salvador de bahia première capitale du
brésil
salvador qui s'enrichit grâce à la canne
à sucre et à la traite des esclaves
[Musique]
ces esclaves sont amenés par bateaux
entiers depuis l'afrique de l'ouest
témoins de l'époque coloniale ce fort
militaire
cette petite église
mais surtout ce vaste bâtiment du xviie
siècle
un bel exemple d'architecturé coloniale
donc mais surtout un lieu de mémoire
pour adolfo roriz architecte à et
descendants d'esclaves
nous sommes face à la baie de tous les
saints et c'est ici qu'arrivaient les
embarcations venues d'afrique
principalement d'angola et du bénin
chargés de marchandises et on les
déposait dans les magasins ici
et ses marchandises étaient ensuite
acheminés vers différents sites dans la
baie
il y avait donc ici des magasins et un
côté une fabrique de sucre
derrière ces murs des centaines
d'esclaves ont broyé la canne à sucre
pour en extraire le jus
le bâtiment lui-même a sans doute été
construit par des esclaves c'est
pourquoi adolphe aurorise tient à le
préserver
mais avoir pour passer ma yan et la
grand-mère maternelle était noir
donc je suis content lorsque je me tenir
face à ce bâtiment ce sens
je me dis que mes ancêtres ont peut-être
participé à sa construction bac on se
sent aujourd'hui ce monument est l'un
des plus importants de salvador
[Musique]
nous voici au coeur de salvador dans le
plus vieux quartier le bel ou rignault
bâti à l'époque coloniale ici les
esclaves ont vécu et travaillé durant
trois siècles
ce quartier historique classé par
l'unesco et restauré depuis 1992 une
restauration qu'adolphe aurorise suit de
très près
ici il connaît chaque maison voici l'une
des mieux conservés elle appartenait à
une riche famille d'origine portugaise
la marche d'entrée ton marbre de carrare
le sol lui est en brique
on a un escalier en pierre de taille
avec des robes ornées de volutes les
marches sont en grève en fait nous avons
une association degré de marne
et pour finir un joli panneau
d'affichage aux portugais
ces carreaux de faïence peints à la main
date du xviie siècle
par deux passages latéraux entraient et
sortaient les cavaliers et les esclaves
la partie noble en eau était réservée à
la famille
pour ces familles riches un intérieur de
luxe
témoin ce plafond en bois polychrome
orné de scènes mythologiques
il a été décoré à la feuille d'or dans
l'esprit de la renaissance italienne
à quelques mètres de là l'église notre
dame du rosaire des noirs
un lieu emblématique car cette église
était réservé à la population noire
jusqu'au xviiie siècle elle est l'oeuvre
d'esclaves et d'affranchis
c'était de la main d'oeuvre qui n'avait
que peu de chances d'accéder aux études
et donc cette église est l'un des
monuments religieux les plus
significatifs à turow niveau historique
elle a été bâtie avec la sueur et le
sang versé gratuitement par les hommes
noirs et l'origne au nez bruce doper
l'audience
comme tous les mardis soir au moment de
la messe l'église fait salle comble
on y vient prier
toujours en musique
et où
ici point de metz sans percussions
afro-brésiliennes la religion catholique
est intimement mêlée à la culture
africaine
[Musique]
à salvador ce métissage est si profond
qu'il ne fait pas de différence entre
les saints catholiques et les divinités
africaines
et
c'est ce qu'on appelle le syncrétisme
illustration le lendemain avec jaws à
une shon bahianaise
nous la rencontrons sur une plage les
bras chargés de fleurs destiné à la ds
lle mandja une déesse africaine
aimant déjà c'est la mère de la beauté
de la paix et aussi des pêcheurs
ok mais dans notre religion catholique
[Applaudissements]
éléments déjà c'est aussi la vierge
marie
gmail
en clair la ds africaines liées mandja
et la vierge marie catholique ne font
qu'une encore un héritage de l'époque
coloniale
en ce temps là les esclaves étaient
contraints de pratiquer la religion
catholique
alors ils donnèrent un non catholiques
achats divinités africaines
aujourd'hui encore le dieu oshana que
voici est jésus-christ
au goût lui est saint-antoine
quant à la dsi janz à elle porte le nom
de sainte barbe une double identité qui
donne lieu à des fêtes très métissée
exemple dans le péloïde you le jour de
la sainte barbe également jour de la dsi
en deçà
[Musique]
à salvador cette fête est un véritable
événement
dans sa chambre joes à se prépare avec
l'aide de sa maman la sainte barbe c'est
une fête à ne pas rater
il faut se faire belle il faut bien se
préparer ce n'est pas une fête comme les
autres il faut porter du rouge
fait cette fête pour moi c'est une fête
guerrière
parce que dans la religion catholique
sainte barbe est associée à la force et
à la foudre
et puis dans la religion africaine janka
est associée au blanc et au rouge aussi
le blanc c'est la couleur du cimetière
et le rouge c'est la guerre
10h du matin dans le mélo mignot
3000 personnes s'apprêtent à fêter
sainte barbe y en deçà à la fois sainte
catholique et ds africaine
joes à se mêle à la foule
ambiance
m
yann et ses costumes typiques mbaye
années n'ont pas changé depuis l'époque
coloniale au temps des esclaves ils sont
portés jusqu'à aujourd'hui
le mouvement il est génial le turban il
vient de nos racines n'est ce pas
montrez vos jupes ans
regardez le petit pantalon de coton
lui il ya cinq jupons comme ça et de en
tissu
il observe que trop lourd tout ça non je
ne pense rien
ça costume il tient chaud où il est
frais il est chaud assez chaud mais ça
suppose on a le sens bayonnais
début de la procession
sainte barbe et yang ça est accueillie
avec une ferveur immense
on se bouscule pour l'approcher
et
c'est très fort vous savez c'est comme
une énergie qui passe dans le sang une
sensation très forte la veille c'est la
première fois que je vois les gens comme
ça à la fête de sainte barbe c'est
vraiment très fort
toujours plus fort nous arrivons à la
caserne des pompiers dernière étape de
la matinée
sainte barbe patronne des
sapeurs-pompiers fait une entrée
triomphale
la procession va se terminer ici en
apothéose
à
et quoi
[Applaudissements]
une fois n'est pas coutume les pompiers
finissent par aspergeaient la foule avec
de l'eau parfumée de l'eau bénite bien
sûr
retour au calme le lendemain matin nous
continuons notre découverte de salvador
la ville métisse
direction l'atelier de goya lopes
une styliste avant gardiste très inspiré
par les traditions africaines et
brésiliennes
la mode créé par goya est une mode
métissée
et
oppose se voir ici les coquillages
divinatoire qui nous viennent de la
culture africaine
et
auquel il ressemble aussi à des grains
de café
hadji également ses motifs qui rappelle
la culture indigène est certain est
donc cette composition est d'inspiration
africaine n'a quand même temps elle
comporte une connotation brésilienne
gouailleur dirige une vingtaine de
personnes et sa petite entreprise tourne
bien
oublier les débuts difficiles
j'ai commencé bien modestement les spams
attentes on a commencé ensemble toutes
les deux j'appris mais je vendais et
elle s'occupait de la future wii je
posais elle elle vendait c'était dur
ah oui ça a été très dur gagner au début
ça a été difficile parce que je ne
réussissais pas à trouver quelqu'un qui
croit dans mon projet
mais avec le temps nous avons réussi à
réaliser notre rêve
nous avons conquis une clientèle et les
affaires sont allées de mieux en mieux
pierre bel
c'était un bon modèle
oh oui très fier
l'atelier de sérigraphie ici sont
imprimés les tissus afro-brésilien
dessiné par goya
sur ce tissu par exemple les motifs
géométriques sont d'origine africaine
l'animal stylisé est inspiré de l'art
indigène brésilien
un métissage qui est en fait
l'expression d'une identité
mon tour et qu'on pour que ces très
riches parce que dans ses compositions
je raconte l'histoire de mon peuple et
ça c'est nouveau et
parce que lorsque je conçois un des
motifs afro-brésilien
je recrée notre histoire en traduisant
tout ce qui existe on nous rappelait
brésilien acquis ou qui n'osent tmz
ça a été un grand
un grand défi certes mais un défi
gagnant
voilà qui donne à coeur joie
séance photo dans le pèlerinage
aujourd'hui le succès sourit à goya
après des années d'efforts
le jeu pour moi ça a été de faire entrer
la culture afro-brésilienne dans la mode
de tous les jours
nous sommes tellement dépendants de la
mode et de la création européenne et
je vais très contente maintenant très
satisfaite que mon projet ce sera
développé et que mon travail se voit
aujourd'hui
autre métissage culturel la musique
ces enfants de salvador apprennent le
samba reggae un mélange de percussions
caribéenne et de samba une musique
populaire venu d'afrique avec les
esclaves
[Applaudissements]
allez mettez vous ici par ici voilà
eloignez-vous les uns des autres
parmi tous ces élèves daniel 14 ans est
déjà passionné
l'émotion ici c'est quand tu jouais
quand tu apprends des choses nouvelles
alors quoi tu penses quand tu joues
un futur rouge pourrait continuer à
jouer comme ça
tout va bien comment ça s'est passé la
répétition
tu penses que ça a bien marché
on va bien donc
nelson est l'un des responsables il
accueille ici gratuitement 300 enfants
issus de milieux défavorisés
au programme danse et musique une
musique qui revendique ses origines
africaines et qui attire de plus en plus
de jeunes bayonnais
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup d'enfants et d'adolescents
défavorisés sont déjà passés par le
système d'éducation olodum aujourd'hui
ils sont sur le marché du travail en
particulier dans le secteur de la
musique alors nous voulons accueillir
encore plus d'adolescents c'est très
important pour eux de participer parce
qu'à travers ce travail il se surpasse
mieux à travers cette musique les
enfants redécouvrent la culture de leurs
ancêtres afro-brésilien une culture et
une histoire très riche dont ils sont
les héritiers
nous leur expliquons le rôle et
l'importance des noirs brésilien leur
contribution à la construction du brésil
il est très important qu'ils aient ses
connaissances
cet héritage afro-brésilien les jeunes
en sont fiers aujourd'hui à l'image de
daniel
enfants des quartiers pauvres qui rêve
désormais d'être roi le roi du samba
reggae
rendez vous avec l'idole des jeunes
bahianais le plus célèbre musicien du
brésil gilberto gil nommé ministre de la
culture en 2003 il nous reçoit chez lui
à salvador témoignage d'un bahianais
métis afro brésiliens et artiste engagé
la culture afro-brésilienne s'est mis en
place tout au long de l'histoire de la
ville avec l'émergence des mouvements
noirs des mouvements de conscience noire
avec leur lutte pour conquérir un espace
social
politique et économique
avec aussi la forte présence de la
musique et de l'art noir dans les cultes
africain
avec enfin les diverses expressions
corporelles comme la danse noire
tout cela a amené la société brésilienne
et en particulier la société bayonnaise
a accepté de plus en plus à la mpt
présence des noix
les différentes dimensions de leur vie à
salvador
[Musique]
dernière journée à salvador nous sommes
au marché saoudien hakim le plus vaste
de la ville
on y trouve toutes les spécialités
culinaires de la région
tania elle vient d'acheter des plants
spéciale on ne les trouve nulle part
ailleurs ce sont des plantes aux vertus
magiques
ces plantes ont un effet énergisant on
absorbe leur énergie et on nettoie notre
corps
tania n'est pas une acheteuse comme les
autres les produits qu'elle vient
choisir sont destinés à des divinités
africaines carte anien prépare une
cérémonie rituelle fidèle aux traditions
de ses ancêtres
bonjour comment ça marche
je veux dire des crevettes
4 kilos de crevettes elles sont vraiment
magnifiques
à combien ils sont
c'est là qu'on aime bien
ces crevettes seront cuisinés en
l'honneur de la déesse si on sort
les genres se demande pourquoi nos
divinités ont besoin de manger le dieu
reçoit cette énergie que nous lui
passons si tu fais tout ça avec beaucoup
d'amour et de tendresse
le dieu dispose de plus de force et
d'énergie alors il nous renvoie cette
force que nous le recevrons de nouveau
avec encore plus d'énergie et de vigueur
c'est vous qui choisissez les
ingrédients et qui cuisinait oui je
choisis ce qu'il ya de meilleur
nous quittons le marché
tania nous emmène dans son tejero la
petite maison paroissiale où se
déroulera la cérémonie rituelle
afro-brésilienne
la responsable du terreiro nous attend
on l'appelle la maire de st elle dirige
toutes les activités rituelles du
quartier tania son assistante et filles
de sa
petite vérification des achats avant que
tania de cuisine ces aliments dans le
plus grand secret
tout était parfait tania l'habitude de
faire ça elle et l'énergie de cette
maison vous avez confiance en elle bien
sûr j'ai confiance en vous n'envoyez pas
n'importe qui ont marché ce n'est pas
possible non il faut que ce soit une
personne de confiance moi en tant que
maire de st je ne pouvais pas aller
personnellement marché
j'ai d'autres responsabilités
là c'est parfait
21h la cérémonie commence
entrée en scène de la mer de saint suivi
des fils et filles de ça
ils sont tous initiés au candomblé une
religion afro brésilienne venue avec les
esclaves yoruba originaire du delta du
niger
la musique les chants les rituels sont
yoruba un patrimoine qui se transmet
oralement depuis cinq siècles au brésil
d'abord pratiqué en secret par les
esclaves l'héritier rumba se vivent
maintenant au grand jour
dans le public joes à catholique
pratiquante mais fidèle occultes
africains de ses ancêtres
au bout d'une heure première transe
selon la religion yoruba ce sont les
divinités qui s'empare des filles et
fils de sang les femmes et les hommes
possédaient perdre toute conscience ils
sont habités par leur dieu
à
[Musique]
les mêmes trans mais au nigeria
ces photos ont été prises il ya 50 ans
par pierre verger un photographe
français fascinés par le culte de la
possession
initié à la religion des yorubas pierre
verger a même obtenu le titre de devant
les divinités sont les mêmes brésil en
afrique que nous ici on n'a pas les
mêmes problème qu'en afrique là bas il
n'y a pas beaucoup de gens qui sont
initiés il n'y a plus vraiment de
culture yoruba
chez nous la culture yoruba et mieux
mises en valeur
dernière partie de la cérémonie les
hommes et les femmes procédés ont revêtu
les habits de leur divinité
ils continueront à danser pendant
plusieurs heures
[Musique]
les spectateurs eux vont se partager la
nourriture cuisiné par tania la fille de
st ces beignets aux crevettes appelé à
car âgées ont été préparés en l'honneur
de la dsi en deçà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette nuit salvador la ville la plus
africaine du brésil vivra au son des
tambours yoruba
[Musique]